sponsored by step finance your go to d5
portfolio manager on solana luno if
you're just getting into bitcoin it's
the perfect place to start
hey guys anna welcome back to another
episode of the lay heil pen show as
always this episode and this podcast is
powered by icon plus capital the vc firm
so go check them out and it is also
sponsored by block fi so block fight
offers some really amazing interest
rates if you're interested i've left a
link in the description and in the
comment section so i think you can get
around nine percent of your stable coins
right now which is pretty cool so
joining me today i have a very special
guest we're talking all about the
american dream we're talking about
privilege we're talking about living in
the most privileged era and of course
we're talking about bitcoin and modern
day society it is charles payne the host
of making money on fox business
charles welcome to the leia hill plan
show it's great to see you how you doing
i'm i'm great it's good to be on your
show
yeah i'm super excited to get into this
um you're a really interesting character
um you have this interesting back story
your upbringing the air force working on
wall street so i want to get into all of
this um and i really want to start at
the beginning basically um so i've
watched several podcasts of yours and
you mentioned that when you were much
younger you moved to harlem and in your
words you grew up dirt poor
um and you had to hustle a lot with
various different jobs from the age of
12. so i'd love to understand where that
drive came from to start hustling
because for a lot of people that kind of
set up in life is just a terrible setup
um and you know it's not a great
foundation so where did that drive come
from
i i think part of it was that i was the
oldest
so there were three boys and my mom
and uh you know and so you know we we
had a beautiful life we grew up around
the world uh living on a us army bases
you know i lived in germany i lived in
japan
texas three times pittsburgh alabama
north carolina virginia so we lived all
over the world and i really never even
thought about money or any of that stuff
i had chores but you know not a lot of
responsibility per se
but then we found ourselves in a sort of
destitute situation where all four of us
are living inside of a room
uh so i just i just i had no i really
felt like i hadn't felt like i had no
choice
uh so you know i just started to hustle
and you know i would
clean car windows you know get a buy a
pack of tall
paper towels some windex
clean
windshields at stop lights and red red
lights and i would shovel snow
and i kind of got lucky i got a job in a
bodega
uh even though that was rough like you
know i i don't think people now
particularly people go to new york and
go to harlem when they go to nice
restaurants understand
in the 1970s it was it was bombed out
parts of it looked like aleppo uh you
know during the syrian war it really was
that bombed out uh junkies winos uh
crime
it was it was rough and even working in
a bodega was pretty rough uh you know
they tested me all the time because i
was different uh you know so lots of
fights a lot of intimidation
but i had no choice i i really felt like
i had no choice
i think it's so interesting that you
said you had no choice because i feel we
live in a society um whereby people are
always sort of talking about um you know
privilege and that's one of the best
ways to get ahead in life
but there's something about having no
choice
which
sort of pushes you it's like it's like a
it's like a rocket right it pushes you
to do better it really is it's um you
know and
you know it's it's so amazing because
i mean obviously not everybody did what
i did right so
uh you know that one intangible i'm not
100 sure where it might have come from i
did i will say you know for my father
who wasn't necessarily i wasn't
necessarily close to
but watching him in the military and the
way he took care of responsibilities you
know
at night i would watch him shine his
boots
and polish his belt buckle until he had
this the most amazing shine and he'd get
dressed in the morning have his gig line
straight put his cologne on
so i did absorb some of that i had a
grandparents on the farm in alabama and
uh you know it's
you know their story is even more to me
even more amazing in the sense that for
a black family to have a farm in the
south
uh you know in the 50s and 60s and 70s
it's really just a mind-boggling thing
and
you know again they went about they took
care of business right they didn't have
indoor plumbing they didn't have
electricity uh you know until like the
late 70s
but they raised a whole lot of kids and
grandkids and they were self-sufficient
they didn't need they needed to take
they didn't need to ask anybody for
anything right so they grew crops they
had a few animals
it was tough work so i think all of
those things contributed to me knowing
that i uh at least thinking i had to
step up so i did
you had clearly really strong um you
know father figure parental sort of
guidance i guess in that sense so
you know money aside because people
always look at money as that privilege
or skin color or you know gender or
whatever it is to what extent would you
say having
um a good example
would be you know that one of the most
privileged things that you could have
oh i think it's far and above the most
important thing and to be quite frank
with you my mom was far and away the
most important symbol in my life the
most important person in my life
uh and so
um
it makes all the difference in the world
you know that's why i'm i'm really big
on family family structure and you know
we live in a modern era so it's not that
hey you know what people are gonna get
married and be be together for 40 years
and for 50 years and
you know but
responsibility so
you may move on marriages may break up
people may never get married but the
responsibility of taking care of
children and giving them hope and you
know teaching them responsibility that's
still very critical and i think that's
where we have fallen off in terms of the
society so uh there's nothing in my mind
more important to that because you're
right it supersedes everything
and in what way do you think we've
fallen off as a society
uh you know just accountability uh just
the notion of lack of responsibility
individual responsibility individual
accountability uh and and
just you know for instance i i find
hiring young people a lot of young
people they don't take criticism well
uh you know or or yeah i just i just
feel like there's a certain kind of
humbleness
that you come up through life with
and and and you know you give respect
you get respect
um
but
there just seems to be so many excuses
that are laid out
and it's so hard to have to be honest
with someone and say hey no this is your
problem but you can fix it but it is a
problem so we skirt around the issues
and
in our world uh you know people don't
commit crimes guns commit crimes right
and our world uh you know it's not what
people do it's it's sort of the outcome
that becomes villainized and and that
never gets to the real issue so i think
we've got some serious issues there uh
and
uh you know a lot of it too is it's just
a country and a world really that has
lost
has lost
i don't i don't say respect but
sort of
we've lost faith in a lot of things and
you know and
i don't go to church every sunday but
i'm a strong believer in god
uh and
uh you know
but we've lost faith in almost every
sort of institution that people used to
look up to as well so you had the family
structure but you also had the church
you believed in your local government
maybe uh you know you believed in
certain things um and these days you
know you look at all these different
surveys and uh our our faith in in these
agencies are have collapsed you know the
only thing i've seen that has gone up in
the last 40 years is
maybe the police department uh but
outside of that whether it's the supreme
court congress the media
uh you know every single one of them
we've lost complete faith in
and again some of that is warranted some
of it also is an excuse because we
started laying off what we should be
achieving on our own to other people you
know oh that guy was bad i i've had
people tell me oh i didn't do well when
reagan was president well that ain't
reagan's fault
i mean yeah you know there's a certain
amount of president can do to set up the
backdrop for you to succeed but
ultimately no matter if it's the worst
president in the world or the best uh
you know
if you grow poor if you grow up rich you
still have to be the author of your life
and that means accepting where you've
made big mistakes and if you do that the
right way you'll be able to correct them
yeah it's this constant sort of um
celebration of victim mentality i think
that's the problem and you know the
whole idea of you know good times create
weak men well it's not just men but it's
people and i always say that western
society sort of peaked in the 90s which
allowed this new generation millennials
unfortunately and one of them to just
become one of the one of the weakest
sort of generations that we've seen
um and so i think you know i think
people
this is also why i love crypto i think
you know people need to be empowered to
um
realize that there is opportunity out
there because i think people often think
that the american dream is sort of dead
um but in in your instance you know
because you did have a difficult
upbringing um like you mentioned
so at what point did you have the
realization that you know the world
isn't against you there is money to be
made out there it is a bit of a game you
know with the stock market you need to
know how to play it and so at what point
did you have that realization because
also because also when you when you do
grow up um
you know not with a dirt poor as you
said you often think that that is normal
you know that is all there is out there
right
well it is normal right i mean for where
you live everyone is in the same boat
i will say the one
uh
serious advantage that i had
over over my neighbors and and the
people i went to school with when i got
to harlem is i had already lived around
the world
and i had i had friends in japan and
they were teaching me japanese and
uh you know i lived in germany and i had
all these different i've gone to all
these different schools and you know i
got to be honest i didn't equate being
great or smart or hard-working or an
intelligent with being white
and you know i was really shocked you
know when i first moved to harlem and i
don't know the first time someone said
man you trying to act like a white boy
and i'm like what do you mean like you
know i want one time you know like
getting straight a's you were trying to
be you were being white
speaking proper english you were being
white so automatically if you tell
yourself that that speaking proper
english is not black you've set yourself
back
you've automatically have put yourself
in such a compromised position that
there's no way in the world you're going
to be able to maximize your potential
and then you compound that with the fact
that there is racism out there
so all it takes is if you even give it a
shot and you get a job somewhere someone
treats you like it really doesn't treat
you well you're gonna say i told you i
knew they were like this i can't make it
we can't make it and so it's a difficult
premise when you've already sort of
established that so i was very very
lucky you know when i was in third grade
third or fourth grade i had a math
teacher
and uh
she her and her husband got their orders
right and they were leaving so it was
her last day
and
once she was the teacher she's my two
kids get a better time
and she would ask a math question
whoever got it right the other kid had
to sit down
i used to run through the entire class i
just crushed them all i would just crush
them all and it was like 95 white kids
and so when she got her order she said
you know everyone i'm leaving and she
asked me if i could stand up and she
said i was the best student she ever had
so in that respect i was lucky like you
know i can't say
i i really do know that that gave me an
advantage over someone who grew up from
day one
thinking that speaking proper english
was being white
or excelling academically was being
white so i did have that advantage and
and that's the thing i wish and i hope
never has to be a disadvantage
that you know as time goes on people
don't have to put themselves down
or look at themselves in a certain way
uh and so
it's it
so there wasn't any particular epiphany
per se
i did have that going for me and
it worked out like when i was going job
interviews i went on a job interview and
i was 17 at mcdonald's
i finished high school but i had six
months before i was going into the air
force i had they had delayed not five
months it was the lake
and i'd said the last thing you wanted
in my neighborhood was to sit around
if you were just sitting around you're
gonna get in trouble one way or the
other
so i went to i saw it out in the paper
they used to have these things called
newspapers by the way
i'm gonna i'm gonna send you one one day
so i i saw an ad in newspaper and i went
down
it was two blocks three blocks away from
it it was ironic because it was trump's
first major building in new york there
there's the grand hyatt hotel
and 300 people showed up for three jobs
and so they did all these rounds of
interviews right they did a round and
then they would get rid of half the
people and do another round so they did
the first round of interviews and then
they got ready for the second round and
when i went over you know they called me
up and went over and the guy says don't
worry about it you're hired already
so i just sat there and i had to wait
like two hours two or three hours for
them to finish the entire process
so in that regard i don't know what i
said to them what they saw in me
but there was definitely something that
made me stand out because i got the job
without having to go through all those
rounds after one round right so
and i think that was sort of the idea
that
you know i i did spend time in different
places and i and i different i
definitely knew different kind of people
and
i don't know if that just came through
or whatever but you know it was it was
well i got the job so that was good
you said something really fascinating
which was um you know
stop acting like a white person so you
know you'd be speaking well or doing
well whatever it is and the response you
would get would be stop speaking like a
white person and i hear that a lot
um i hear that you know obviously i'm
based in the uk but you know it's the
same conversation i hear and it sort of
reminds me of the whole crabs in a
bucket sort of idea
i'd like to understand you know why you
think that happens because you know
you're sort of damned if you're doing
dams if you don't right because like you
said that compounded with actual racism
that exists you're sort of damned either
way
right
you know and i've heard the term crabs
in a bucket the only thing i would say
the crabs are all trying to save
themselves they don't know they're
pulling the other one down with human
beings we know we're pulling each other
down
um so
uh
you know listen it was really even
rougher than that because i mean i took
some serious ass weapons right for for
sounding like a white person really
oh let me tell you one of the first
things i that that that the difference
between growing up on army bases and
living in harlem in the 1970s were the
for the fights the physicality
you know i had like two fights maybe
three i know for a fact i had two when i
lived on these army bases one man me and
my friend we had a fight we were playing
football
and you know
i this fight lasted i think two minutes
one minute and then we finished and then
we were friends again you know and we
played finished the football game and we
had a soda pop
the other one was uh this with this kid
and we rolled around on the ground for a
while but again you know it was no big
deal i didn't realize like you know we
moved to new york it was like yo you
fight to the death
you start fighting you and you i'm my
longest fight i mean this kid fought for
40 minutes one time
we covered three blocks i don't even
know how the hell we got there like you
know you just fight and all of a sudden
no one would break it up
and it's just like you know so
so it was dangerous to sound like a
white kid
it was like oh god
uh you know do i really want to get an a
right now i went home from school and i
damn sure had to run home from school
so
you know it was um
you know the the the thing is though and
and this is why i'm praying and hoping
that one day we can change that
so there's not that internal pressure
you know
and you know it's
it's it's easier said than done you know
it's it's a it's a societal thing
um you know um every now and then you
see a nice disney movie i remember keela
and the bee and this girl was in a crime
infested neighborhood but she was great
at spelling and nobody bothered it right
you know just
it's just you know it's a prayerful
thing that we get to that point um
um we're not there yet even as a society
i don't think you know race excluding
race we don't appreciate
uh intellect the way the rest of the
world does and i'll give you a great
example there's a guy named jim clark
i'm not sure if you ever heard of him
i think he may have the distinction of
being the only person who created three
separate multi-billion dollar
corporations i think his first one was a
company called netscape
so jim clark
this guy wrote a book about him um
michael lewis
michael lewis is like one of the most
famous authors when it comes to you know
wall street books
and so he wrote a book about jim clark
called the new new thing
and in the book there's a part in there
and i got to buy the book i was looking
at my library the other day and i
couldn't find it but i remember there
being a partner where there was a guy
who was always with jim clark a guy from
india
so lewis said you know can i talk to him
so he interviewed this guy
and uh during the course of the
interview the guy he came from a small
village in india
and
he's like you know talking about his
background and his sister was the
prettiest girl in the village
and one day he came home from school and
she was getting all gussied up right
it's like oh what's going on she's like
i got his date and so he says well with
who and when she told him he's like
golly he's like the ugliest guy in the
village but you know what his sister
said
yeah but he's the smartest right
you know we don't you know smart people
in our country get you know you know
they you know it's the captain of the
football team the guy who can rap the
best the guy who can dunk the ball all
right those are the ones who put on
pedestals
often the people who are very really
smart have to hide it
uh and you know that's a detriment it's
it's always been a detriment but even
more so as we go into this new economy
uh which is more intellectually based
and you know based on physical brawn
yeah it is an interesting idea and you
know i think
speaking of moving into this new economy
where
it is very tech driven and you know we
always talk about this um on your show
people often say that we live in the
most privileged era where we have access
to unlimited information where you can
build an empire from your mom's basement
if you've got some good wi-fi you know
you can really do anything from anywhere
you can access a global market so
would you agree firstly that we do live
in one of the most privileged times
absolutely
absolutely uh you know there's just no
there's just no doubt about it you know
just like you said the reach the ability
to
you know to start a business you know
put out some ads on facebook or whatever
it's it's that you know but it also is
competitive right i mean the ease of
ease of entry means there's a billion
other people doing it right so
you know whereas if it was harder you
would have maybe fewer competitors but
penetrating the market and creating a
business uh that part is really great
and when i started my business
because you know i have my own business
aside from fox yeah yeah so when i
started my business i started again out
of a one bedroom apartment in harlem
it's a research business and
what i would do is i i would write the
research at night
and then i was a salesman in the daytime
and there was this big book it was
really thick it had to be like at least
a foot i mean they used to call it the
red book it had a red cover it was a
directory of all the brokers in america
and i would just go through the red book
calling people up cold calling
you know hey you should try my research
to try my research you know how hard
that is
you know and so it's a grind uh you know
but
it is what it is right
yeah i mean i just i just wonder then
you know given i also think we live in
one of the most privileged times um
so i'm trying to understand you know why
there is this sort of growing unrest in
america and also globally um in terms of
this whole diversity narrative
um this idea that you know we live in
the most oppressed times women are the
most depressed well as a woman i totally
disagree i think we're the most
liberated right now and i think that's
sort of bad in some ways but that's
another it's another that's another
topic um
but you know surely technology has
leveled that playing field so why if we
can agree it's the most privileged times
why are we apparently more oppressed
than ever
you know i think that's more of a
political narrative than anything else
you know there's a lot of power out
there to make people feel oppressed to
make people hate each other to make
people feel animosity uh and and the
power centers of our country of our
countries and around the world really
the west in particular but certainly in
the united states is centered on
grievance and
and you know when you start to take that
away
then these organizations can't exist
the day after the day after barack obama
was elected
i got an email from the nc uh uh
national association for advancement of
colored people
um
that was ominous
that you know
now that obama's elected it's going to
be worse for black people
so
because you know there's there's a
backlash even to this day you hear
people you know
talk
you hear people say oh you know now the
races are going to really come out
you know so there's a backlash you know
uh it's it's it's nonsensical in a sense
that uh you know this is the same
country that elected a black man but
then they hate him at the same time it
just doesn't make sense if you step back
even for a nanosecond and pay attention
but that's the narrative because they
can't give up what are they going to do
say we don't want to be in business
anymore they're going to fold up their
tent you know people are going to give
up those six-figure jobs and their
privilege and their speeches and they're
going to give all that up and do what
you know and and you know it's the same
thing whether it's unions whether it's
that whether it's this no one's going to
give up that power uh and so it's the
the oppression meal ticket is a
multi-billion maybe fifty hundred
billion dollar thing and the power that
comes with it is amazing as well
so and you know same thing with
political power you know and that's
that's why i hate politicians who who
spend too much time telling me about
someone that hates me or that spends too
much time
telling me what the other person's doing
i always want to hear what they're going
to do um you know and
you know
it's it's it's gotten very despicable
and i think it's going to get more
despicable because you have these older
politicians
who have no clue
that you know people younger people your
age and even younger
are closer than anyone else you know
like you know it has ever been
you know again if you go back to my old
block there were no white people zero
zero
and you know you couldn't meet any
unless you maybe had a few at school
you couldn't there was no internet to
meet any you couldn't share the music
you know there was not no way to
interact with any white person of course
now that's all people do is interact
with different people all around the
world
you know so
i think it's a beautiful thing
um but there's some really powerful
nefarious forces that hate to see it
happen
yeah i think it's really sad because i
also agree i think it's a beautiful
thing um you know i'm not one of those
um people that scream diversity i'm just
happy to live in a meritocracy um you
know equality of opportunity rather than
outcome um but it's so funny because you
know people always scream oh you're
sexist racist this all that if you just
sort of want to see a meritocracy
um
that is no i i guess because there's
there's it's rare that there truly is a
true meritocracy there's always
something that kind of tilts something
in someone's favor a little bit which is
this real talk you know it's it's like
you know you go and you start the job
same time as someone else maybe they
went to school with the boss or the
boss's daughter or the same alma mater
they live in the same town they like the
same movie there's always kind of
something
that you know it's hard to find in this
world of isms and it's not just racism
or sexism or you know there's all kinds
of elitism and this isn't so
you know i i don't ever tell anybody
that that i don't know too many areas
where there's truly
uh true meritocracy but
i do know the harder you work the harder
it's going to be hard for someone to
stop you
you know what i mean like if you bust
your ass and you learn and you overcome
you become a battering ram i don't give
a damn the more you become a battering
ram the harder it is for someone to stop
you so
you know and the reason i say that
because i don't want people to get
disillusioned like well i did everything
else they did well then whatever else
you got to do do it right because
because
if you want that you've got to go get it
and and no one's going to give it to you
they'll give you crumbs
they'll give you crumbs all day long
you know uh higher minimum wage yeah
step right up vote for me i'll give you
a higher minimum wage you want to live
in a project public housing i'm your man
you know oh i'll raise you above the
poverty line so what does that really
mean well in america that means we'll
take a family of four from 26 000 a year
to 27 000 a year you know so you know so
i i i do i believe in meritocracy as
well but i just think it's it's i've
never been in a position anywhere in my
life where
just truly the best and the hardest
working uh is an automatic path you know
sometimes it takes a little bit more
than that and it's fine because you know
what you have sharp elbows look at you
you're a dynamo
right so no one if you if you sense some
[ __ ] you're gonna you're gonna
sharpen your elbows and you're gonna
still power right through it
yeah i mean i just yeah i still just try
my best um because i want certain things
i want so
you know like my my whole mentality is
like i don't wanna rely on anyone or
anything
um you know and it's not a feminist
mentality at all because i'm really not
into that um i just i just think we all
have to be careful in this world because
you never know what tomorrow brings you
know even if it's just like bad health
you know sure oh you're going to be able
to pay those bills if it's a family
member that's sick you want to be able
to pay those bills like i just don't
want to struggle you know
um and and even on just like a
superficial level like if i'm not being
funny but if i want to get another
perfume i don't want to ask someone for
that i want to be able to go and afford
a chanel perfume myself like
i know that sounds superficial but it's
just i don't want to ask i want to be
able to do you know and and then also
just giving back as well which is really
which is which is which is the next
level of like achievement um when you
can give back and
and i feel like that's something you're
doing actually um like i really love
what's going on right now with fox
business i love that you're bringing in
i wasn't gonna ask you about this but
i'm just gonna do it anyway i love that
you're bringing in loads of people from
crypto twitter um you know young people
like myself people younger than me um i
think it's incredible i'm not i'm not
seeing this anywhere else actually a
little bit in the uk but
that's more for diversity reasons in my
opinion um but tell me about this how
come you're you know you're really
talking about crypto and bringing in
young people it's not even just crypto i
just want young people i you know why
first and foremost
like you i believe in economic freedom
right personal freedom is just it's just
let me tell you something sometimes i
walk out my bedroom door and i look down
on my house
and the feeling is just like oh my
goodness i can't even describe it like
you know it's like look at this amazing
house right it's like look at this it's
a [ __ ] mansion right and yeah and i
earned this [ __ ] from nothing i had
nothing i don't know how i got there i
really couldn't tell you exactly
and
and i want this for people particularly
young people
and you know i got to be honest
you're very observant because
no one is doing what i'm doing in terms
of like how how much time i spend
looking for new guests
all the time
and you know i'm looking at i like i
like to find people who who write
or who seem to you know who know what
they're talking about i you know i like
to read the reporting or whatever
uh
you know and and i just think
that if we empower
younger generations
then then that's how we keep this thing
going right because it's not we're not
ordained and none of us are you know
like i know
listen i think america right for what is
achieved in such a short period of time
considering how old civilization is is
absolutely remarkable you know the super
you know the pass up the great great
britain in the 1900s early 1900s
um but i also believe that a lot of
people have gotten to the point where
they think it's ordained
you know just kind of wake up yeah god
blessed america yeah well you got to get
up and earn it though yeah
you just got to sit back and you know
because
you know once because once you lose it i
don't think you get it back so
so you know i and i just and by the way
i'm i love what i'm seeing with young
investors and it's just and it's crypto
but it's also stocks
and and i just i i love it because it
was it was my salvation
you know i when i was 14 i went and i
told my mom i said i'm gonna work on
wall street that's amazing and let me
tell you
nobody but my mom believed me
nobody i called my dad on the phone
i said daddy i'm gonna work on wall
street you say man i saw it on tv one
bunch of white guys throwing paper in
here
i see no he said i see no black people
down there like thanks dad
i'm gone that's so amazing i just i love
that so much i think that's that's what
it's all about for me um you know that's
why i'm interested in bitcoin um because
i feel like it really levels the playing
field um and it brings back that fresh
opportunity you know and i know
millennials often feel like the um the
opportunity is gone you know it's hard
to get on the property ladder the
infrastructure is built now america's
built everything's built um but now
we're building new things um and so it's
finally an opportunity um
to start again so this leads me to my my
next point so i thought you're an
example of the american dream um and i
love it um
so
to what extent would you say the
american dream is dead
you know given inflation
biden and all that fun stuff um you know
the wars the centralization of power and
all this stuff versus a new era that was
sort of going into
i don't i don't think it's dead you know
i just think people have to to work for
it right and you know it's you think of
some of the other generations and the
greatest generation in world war ii
world war one world war ii
uh even people who young people who
fought in vietnam you know my dad fought
in vietnam and to be honest with you
when he came back he was never the same
and sadly
um he only told me a little bit about
that just a few months before he died
why he changed and
twice he had gone out with his crew
whatever you know
and twice he was the only one who
survived
and so he was mad at god he was mad at
everyone
you know that and it was hard for him to
love to be vulnerable
so there are generations that all face
obstacles
um
so i think the american dream is alive
and well it's got to be you got a 22
trillion dollar economy are you kidding
me but you got to you got to get in
there right and again it's easier to set
it up but that means there are more
people maybe doing it that means you
gotta be smarter more innovative you
still gotta have that hustle that grind
um you know and and
i just think too many people have grown
up without it and they don't know how to
get it
uh
and you know and and so
ultimately you know getting becoming
very successful
is not luck right you know
every now and then maybe someone may
stumble on something but for the most
part it is a dedication a grind
overcoming obstacles getting smacked
down a few times climbing back off the
canvas
that kind of thing so
the american dream is alive and well and
like you though i think what's happening
you know blockchain crypto you know the
metaverse um
you know just this whole new world
uh you know listen i i'm a i you know
the story ned lud
no
so so when they first had the weaving
machines
uh you know he was really upset his name
like king led net love they called him
king lud anyway he led a revolt one
night because people were losing their
jobs right you know it took like all
these women and men who were making
these you know things he they started
bringing these big machines i was doing
the work of like 10 people
so one night him and a bunch of people
broke into like a little
factory and they broke them up so anyone
who's afraid of advancement now is known
as a luddite
right or technology so i'm something of
a luddite not that i'm afraid of it but
you know i'm not the best at it you know
i actually get on the phone on the
elevator like it took me so damn long to
get a smartphone but i was also
embarrassed so when i would get on the
elevator my like old school phone i
would be acting like i was sending an
email even though because everybody else
was in an email
me too but um
so i i'm sort of a luddite right
but
i think we're in a fourth industrial
revolution yeah and so you know robots
flying taxis and all of these things are
just so absolutely amazing
the sad thing though is if you don't
prepare for it
the right way you're going to be left
behind
and so we're going to have a we're going
to have another group of haves and
have-nots and this won't be based on
race as and and all the other things is
to be based more on intellect and and
you know people who have actually
prepared for it invested in it or
learned about it
and then it would be the rest
yeah i think you're absolutely spot on i
totally agree with you that's why i'm
investing like i'm crazy right now i'm
just trying to like every day i'm like
yeah i'm in on that new [ __ ] coin i'm in
on that new meme coin i don't care just
just put it in um
yeah i'm going crazy with it um but i'd
love to understand how you first heard
about bitcoin and crypto and you know
what was your initial thoughts when you
first heard about it
um i heard about it a long time ago i
read about it somewhere a long time ago
and i thought it was very very
intriguing
but my my biggest obstacle was this
notion that some kind of super formula
was created some sort of software and
it'd only be x amount of um
uh hold on i'm sorry no worries
hello
okay
yeah so um
there would be x amount you know i just
thought
i loved listen i'm not a fan of fiat
currency i do think
uh you know that that
i i do believe one day this whole thing
will implode i don't know what this the
final
thing will be that makes it implode it
might be something small right like all
these major structures that eventually
collapse it's not as you know if you get
so deteriorated beneath the surface that
it won't take much but
i don't know what the magic number is or
what it is but they've just ruined it so
badly
um so i just never trusted the idea that
this formula was foolproof
so i used to have an office also on the
17th floor here and john stossel uh
who's a real famous newsman in america
um
he was into it early
and it's uh one of his assistants she
was into it early she's always come by
the office and this is like it was like
three thousand right you surprised some
of that bitcoin i'm like yeah yeah yeah
okay yeah i hear you you know
so i was always into interested in that
they want to collapse the first time
i kind of like say yeah okay that's what
i thought
but when it made the rebound that's when
it got started getting my attention then
i learned more about the blockchain than
about you know the you know the
the sort of decentralized financing
and um you know i just became more and
more intrigued
yeah i want to pick you up on your point
about the dollar um do you think the
dollar is at risk of losing its place
in the world um as you know that world
reserve currency um you know i imagine
for example inflation is so much more
than 7.9
um
so what's gonna you know i know you
don't know exactly how but like people
are losing
trust in the us dollar yeah
will it lose it's you know will it lose
it it's gone i think it would have
already if there was an alternative
right the only thing that you can say is
that everybody has to base their
currency
right you know you look at the european
central bank the bank of england the
bank of japan i mean some of the things
they've done is like ah lee they're
buying stocks right so
they've all gone off the reservation
right um
uh but i do believe it's interesting
because today one of my topics is as
saudi arabia buying oil in the yuan
rather than a dollar
those are your first signs you know one
of the main things that keeps the dollar
the world's reserve currency is that
people pay for oil with dollars
which is why this whole push
by progressives in america to get rid of
oil they are so damn stupid for so many
reasons it's like you guys don't realize
you're gonna you're just gonna make it
easier to get off the us dollar and that
full faith and credit that gets you a
lot of stuff
you know that gets all this money coming
into here into this country is gonna go
away it's going to go to taiwan it's
going to go to vietnam it's going to go
to china it's going to go to africa
all that money that we get in part
because of a rule of law
all right and and and you know and just
all the things that make you the world's
reserve currency one of the big parts of
it is crude oil so i just find it so
amazing they want to get rid of it they
have no clue
no clue unless they really do want
you know maybe they want some form of
armageddon because that's what they're
going get
uh and and and so
it will at one point at some point it
will lose that uh for a few years ago
maybe a decade ago there was a talk of a
basket of currencies sort of like what
the imf has
imf has these five five currencies in a
basket
and that's sort of what they call a
special drawing rights
uh and so there's been there was talk of
maybe a special drawing rights
uh superseding the dollar so it would be
the yuan
uh the euro the dollar
uh and uh the pound and i forgot what
the other thing was
maybe the swiss franc so mm-hmm or no
the swiss doesn't frank anymore whatever
it was something else but
so it will lose it at some point it's
inevitable
yeah and you said it's you know
there's no alternative but i mean do you
see bitcoin at this stage as being an
alternative obviously not right now but
you know el salvador's adopting bitcoin
as legal tender um you know i'm starting
to see some states in the u.s um talking
about allowing people to pay their taxes
and bitcoin which for those watching
don't do that i think that's a terrible
idea for many reasons um
so
you know you're always asking me on the
show but what about you like where do
you see bitcoin's role in the world i i
think it's got to evolve you know here's
the thing i think we got bitcoin uh you
got two things it's got to overcome a
few tests right you know to prove itself
um you know you know these transitions
just don't happen overnight i think you
taught me that
and um
and it's got opposition you know
we talked i was talking earlier to you
about these powerful entities that want
to keep their power no matter what and a
lot of their power is based on you know
grievance and and animosity of people
toward other people but the ultimate
power of these world governments
i mean imagine them giving up fiat
currency
golly like you know the notion that they
couldn't print themselves out of a jam
anymore
whoa are you serious it's like
you know i mean it's it's it's it's
unthinkable
it's unthinkable think about how much
money has been printed in the last four
years than the last 10 years just out of
thin air between all these central banks
imagine giving that up
so now you really have to solve problems
through serious belt tightening through
years of recessions you know
uh or or they would call them um
uh with golly what was the name of them
before
you know they got rid of the name and
and in the 1880s there were like four of
these big giant great recession type
periods
oh man i don't know if it's the 80s
maybe no no in the 1880s
yeah
depression nothing not depression golly
they had a different name for it anyway
they actually changed the name because
it was so rough and that's when they
came up this this is you know the
federal reserve in the early 1900s and
they were supposed to stop this boom
bust cycle and they said if we ever have
it again we're not going to call it that
they said let's just call it a
depression so anyway
they would be these you know they had to
ever have to gut it out if these
countries ever had to gut it out you
would talk about 12 years
of recession
you know there would be 20 years of
depression and they they don't want to
go through that so
they're to fight tooth and nail
to make sure bitcoin never
achieves its ultimate potential doesn't
mean they're going to be successful but
they are going to fight tooth and now to
make sure it never happens
yeah i'm so ready for it i'm so ready
i've got some lip gloss
i've got a very sharp lip liner charles
hey you can put a wick in that lip gloss
lighting and throw it maybe you know
okay
there you go nobody you know the reason
i say i'm ready for it is because um
the last two years for me have just been
so inhumane um you know
you know forcing medical procedures and
so on and so on so i think
people are not just losing trust in the
us dollar but they like you mentioned
earlier they're losing trust in the
establishment as a whole whether it's
news media unfortunately you know i
think cnn were very confused as to why
people preferred joe rogan over cnn um
that wasn't that much of a shocker um
you know and also um you know the the
medical industry now unfortunately
people are losing losing faith in so
in your opinion you know where do we go
from here like how do we how do we heal
as a society because we're becoming more
divided um you know
it was black versus white then it was
vaccinated versus unvaccinated now it's
like russia versus ukraine and you know
if you don't say anything then you're
pro-putin um you know it's it's just
crazy it's like we we just have to we
argue over everything and we just don't
need to you know
um i i think the uh you know you kind of
you kind of answered it a little bit
when you brought up brogan versus cnn so
you're talking about
right you're talking about uh one entity
that used to you know that doesn't even
get a million viewers versus one who
gets 11 million
um you know i think and i think it
happens when we start to bypass
all of these folks who tell us how to
think
and they tell us how to think not
not out of altruistic reasons
but to again to preserve their power
all right so msnbc all day long oh my
god just i didn't do they ever get tired
of blaming trump for everything
could they ever get tired of promoting
hate do they ever get tired of it
you know um might not come as a shock to
you but i watched very little
uh cable news or any news that it
doesn't come as a shocking tool
very little very little um
you know when i'm not when i'm not
working i love movies and um old tv
shows
i've been watching the original year of
hawaii five of you ever want to find a
great series i've been watching the
first season of that that's some amazing
tv anyway i digressed a little bit
nah it's good
but i think i think it'll happen you
know as as we find a way to communicate
and bypass the gatekeepers and the
opinion makers
and once we start to do that because
people will find hey you know what i get
a lot in common with this other person
and and again i'm seeing it already you
know
uh you know i see it with my son who by
the way went to university in london
oh nice yeah yeah and
he just had an art show this week and
his best friend from london came over
they're coming to the studio today oh
amazing yeah so
and then of course you know you know i
looked at him and his friends you know
his first girlfriend was from sweden his
best friend another best friend was from
the middle east another one was from
africa and you go over there and you
hang with them and you just kind of sit
back and like you know they just love
each other you know because of who they
are
and no one can make them not love each
other
and so
as we get rid of those power structures
that just live off that that crap
um
i think we'll have a reawakening in what
we can do and achieve on our own
and that's why i'm really if you ever
see me on tv going off and politics is
always on stuff like
know like higher minimum wage stuff like
that that you know just anything that
keeps you dependent
uh on on government anything that stops
you
from being able to nurture your
god-given gifts because i believe
everybody has god-given gifts but i
think you know often you have to nurture
them you have to see them find them
nurture them and if you don't nurture
them if you if you do a foul-stand deal
and you keep them suppressed and in
return you take free a higher minimum
wage and free this and free that
you've actually destroyed your life
you've destroyed the gifts that you've
never even led blossom
in exchange for crumbs
yeah i i totally agree with you i think
that's such an eloquent way
of putting it i also hate minimum wage
it's so counterproductive um it
literally screws the very people they're
trying to help and i often wonder
whether it's destruction by design right
like whether they do this on purpose um
to keep you dependent that's sort of the
way the democrats look i don't know what
do you think
design op
essence um
you remember that term
uh there's a term i think it's design
ops
ah oppolepsince
uh golly now i'm mumbling here when
things are designed to go become
obsolete
oh oh oh like they say about like apple
and tech
um
um obsolete is my dad uses it what is it
yeah it's it started back in i think
yeah
60s
early 60s or late 50s
um designed obsolescence yeah
yeah i think yeah yeah i think that's it
so i think um
i think this guy i want to say he was um
anyway one of the auto executives uh
talked about it and you know the cars
were designed to work a certain amount
of time and then break
yes
right so you have to buy another one and
the same thing to your point with
society
you know it's designed a certain way
because if you ever have to supersede
the need
to take their crumbs they're nothing
they have nothing over you
yeah you lose their job you don't have
to vote for them
yeah no i i i totally agree with you um
i'd like to get your thoughts as well um
on the current crypto regulation biden's
executive order um i feel like the roles
are turning right now this is what you
would ask me but what are your thoughts
charles on on biden's executive order
uh you know what i was shocked at how
many of my crypto guests thought it was
good news
i guess i guess it's um that's why
you're my favorite crypto guest uh thank
you
i guess
it's good in a sense that
it's orderly
yes right you know i mean you got you
know it's not the wild wild west where
everyone comes in like you know you
imagine a town with 25 different
sheriffs right and they all have their
own rules like oh man hey what are you
told you can drink out of there uh the
sheriff so-and-so well you can't okay
so maybe yeah you know maybe we'll get
all of it down into one
you know into one package and one set of
rules but what the hell are those rules
going to be
so also
if you saw the testimony of jay powell
you know
these are called the humphrey hawkins he
goes up to congress and he speaks to
congress to the house and then the
senate
oh my goodness i mean he was
he was really talking about you know
this need for this central bank digital
currency
elizabeth warren used all her time to
rail against the nefarious evilness of
bitcoin
uh you know and yeah and that's
something that's bipartisan you have
people on both sides of the aisle so
yeah you know what let's go where we've
got to go i know in early may all of all
the comments have to be in on the
central bank cryptocurrency
uh then after that they'll look at them
and then i i would suspect in about a
month after that we'll get the next move
from the fed
uh but
i'm just a little i'm just a little
anxious that's all i'm just a little
anxious and i've already told you i just
can't see them allowing this
to blossom to its full potential without
trying to sabotage it
yeah i think we're in um
that fight stage um which is just a
phase um i think we will pass it
anything new always goes through always
goes through those stages i love your
optimism
oh thank you no it's true i think so i i
really think so i think it's just you
know i look at it also quite like
philosophical like good will prevail and
i think bitcoin is good i think it's
humanitarian money um and you know um
we're just going through a cycle right
now right now we're hitting peak
centralization but i don't think that
will last um a guest on one of my shows
said there's going to be a blow off top
um in terms of um you know
decentralization just blowing through
because
because it's become too much
um
and yeah i think it's gonna be really
interesting i'm kind of grateful
actually that i'm living at during a
time where we can witness all of this
right right yeah um but just finally um
two more questions for you some if
somebody had to do 50 000
clear and free today um and you have a
choice to either buy bitcoin
or buy gold and you have to hold it for
10 years which are you buying charles
i would buy bitcoin
why
i think it's got more upside potential
uh you know i i you know
you know i've i've got boats i probably
haven't uh i got more money into gold
only because i was buying it a long time
ago yeah that makes sense uh and every
now and then and i like by the way i
like the gold bars right i mean i have
two
nothing but you know the big ones the
things like
you know
yeah the only thing is i don't know
where they are like my wife took them
put them somewhere and i keep saying
like you know where's my goal
no i got it i i'm like can i get my gold
please anyway
um you need better self-custody charles
come on oh yeah yeah
so
i would you know i
i think gold will have a position but i
think like you i think bitcoin has so
much upside potential
so definitely i would buy bitcoin over
gold if i had to buy one or the other
right now that's a good one um and then
just finally um given everything that
we've spoken about um and it's been a
great conversation um
what would be your number one advice uh
your top you know the top sort of line
that you would say to people wanting to
make it in this world um
sort of feeling like you know everything
sort of against them right now and
you know looking to rise above their
circumstances what would be the number
one piece of advice you'd give them
i i uh
you have to make it you really have to
make it happen um
it's not there's it's not going to come
out of fairness of the system
uh there are going to be people that you
meet who are going to be incredibly kind
and generous you don't know where
they're going to be
you know who they're going to be
uh you know and and i've been so
fortunate that every
now and then
while there was a teacher you know here
or a person there but just every now and
then someone just kind of nudged me a
little bit
so that's going to happen people should
know that's going to happen but none all
of this happens when you stay in the
fight
when you stay in the fight and you're
committed to being a better version of
you
you're gonna succeed
and again you can go down you can go
sideways but if you still go home that
night and do your work and do your
research and you put in the extra time
if you're a better version of yourself
every single day you're going to make it
charles i want to thank you so much it's
been such a pleasure speaking with you i
love your your intellect i like your
passion your hustle your drive your love
of personal responsibility and you know
your respect i think we need more of
that in this world um i think absolutely
brilliant so thank you so much for
coming on thank you so much yeah you're
you're fantastic too i'm glad to know
you
the leia fan show
sponsored by step finance your go-to d5
portfolio manager on solana luno if
you're just getting into bitcoin it's
the perfect place to start